Speaker 1: We are now going to look in
this segment and in the next segment
at some of the speeches at the Turning Point
USA Student Summit. Okay, this was in Tampa,
Florida. Now we're going to start with Donald
Trump's WWE style entrance to the summit. And
I know that you're going to see this and you're
going to cringe. And when I see it, I cringe. But
just remember, the left doesn't have anything
like this. The right engages people with this
stuff. It's so stupid and it's so fundamentally
vapid, but they fund stuff to activate people.
They fund stuff to get people excited, and
we just fail. On the left. Take a look at
this introduction for Trump.
Speaker 3: People were.
And I fight harder for you than
any president has ever had.
We will win again. We will win,
win, win back. And people where
you're fired. The most loyal people. A
Trump supporter. Because they like it when.
That's why the American flag. I think I'd be a
really good president. I'm a great. They should
be in jail. In the meantime, I'm president
and you're not supposed to trade for work.
And I fight harder for you than any president
has ever had.
Unidentified:
We're going to make America
great again. Thank you very much.
Speaker 3: Ladies and.
Speaker 4: Gentlemen,
please welcome the 45th President of the
United States of America, Donald J. Trump.
Unidentified: To be an American.
Speaker 1:
Okay. And there's pyrotechnics going and
eventually Trump comes out. So it's a
complete and total joke. But they know how to
engage people. They're getting young people
engaged. And unless the left figures out how
to fund stuff like this and how to effectively
coalesce people around candidates and ideas,
it's not looking particularly good. Now,
on the substance, the speech that Trump
gave to the Turning Point USA people was
completely unhinged. At one point,
Trump said he wanted to give himself
the Congressional Medal of Honor.
Speaker 3: In fact, as president,
I wanted to give myself the Congressional
Medal of Honor. But they wouldn't let me do it.
They wouldn't let me do it. I said, I'm going
to give myself and I've always wanted that,
but they wouldn't let me do that. They said
that would be inappropriate. I said, okay, it.
Speaker 1: Would look bad for Trump to do that.
One of the most stunning things Trump will
sometimes do is he will tell stories about flying
on private jets, either his own or Air Force One,
and not exactly relatable to most people in
the crowd. But Trump's audience here in Florida
sat silently as Trump told the
bizarre, rambling story about Air
Force One just really not reading the room.
Speaker 3: You can believe it. You know,
Air Force One is actually two planes. It's
too big, 740 sevens. So they were ordered.
But we're on the plane flying over and we're
about an hour away from the big airfield that
we're landing in in Iraq. And I get a call and
then some military people came in to see me. You
know, this is like a a large home, Air Force
One, very big a lot of people on the plane,
most talented people you've ever seen, including
the pilots. The most incredible people.
Sir, would you please do us a favor? We'd like
to close all of your windows. I say why? We don't
want any light on the plane. I said, Why is that?
Because we don't want the enemy to see us. Think
of it. We've been there for 20 years and we can't
fly an airplane into the country. I said, That's
pretty sad. So they closed down all of the shades.
Everything was absolutely dark and they said, Sir,
we're going to be turning off the lights and
the plane. I said, What do you have to do that
we just closed all the shades and the windows?
Speaker 1: He really has a way with words. I mean,
just a riveting, absolutely riveting storyteller,
as you can see. Donald Trump claimed that
nursing home residents really don't don't vote
that much because they're very busy dying.
Speaker 3: Wisconsin, they said nursing home,
the nursing home scandal, nursing homes typically
don't vote too much. You know, people are dying.
They've got other things on their mind, but they
got almost 100% of the people in nursing homes.
Speaker 1: So Trump very confused about what goes
on in nursing homes. And then Trump
again playing up the victims stuff,
saying he's the most persecuted person in
American history. Again, another part of
the speech that the crowd was silent during.
Speaker 3: A friend of mine recently said
that I was the most persecuted person in
the history of our country. Me the most
persecuted. I never thought of it that way.
I never had time. I was always fighting with
these people that were trying to persecute me. I
didn't have time to think about being persecuted
because I was fighting persecution. Mm. When
I thought about it, now I sit back. He's a
very smart guy. Successful, I thought, check
back. I said, you know, he may very well be
right. Certainly there's been no politician or
president treated like I've been treated right.
Speaker 1: No one's been treated worse than Trump.
As he continues to remind us then the Christian
nationalist moment of the speech. We're going
to talk about this more tomorrow. In general,
the Republican Party going in this Christian
nationalist direction. Trump again with this.
Americans kneel before God and God alone.
Speaker 3: We will not break. We will not
yield. We will never give in. We
will never give up. We will never,
ever, ever back down. As long as we are
confident and united the tyrants we are fighting,
do not stand a chance because we are Americans
and Americans kneel to God and God alone.
Speaker 1: Right. And that is another allusion to
the Christian nationalism of the modern Republican
Party. And then Trump capping off his speech to
these young conservatives with some transphobia.
That's a big part now of every Trump speech.
Speaker 3: You can't teach the Bible, but you
can teach children that America is evil and that
men can get pregnant. A man can get pregnant.
Can't even talk about the Bible. You would not
trust these people to babysit your children for
20 minutes. And why should we then let them
educate millions of American students 6 hours
a day, year after year after year?
Speaker 1: And then also Trump
misgendering trans people and
goading the crowd into booing
them. This is another staple of the Trump speech.
Speaker 3: In a very sad state. It already is. Our
country has never been in a position like this
before. Happened all in a short period of time.
Across the United States, we need to implement
strict prohibitions on teaching inappropriate
racial, sexual and political material to America's
children in any form. We will also keep men out of
women's sports. Is that okay? Right.
Speaker 1: You believe?
Notice how fired up the crowd gets. I
mean, they've convinced these people
in the crowd that that transport's
issue is like an issue of paramount
importance in the United States.
Unidentified: Keep men out of limos.
Think of a. Now, I've.
Speaker 3: Told this story a number
of times. You know, the swimmer with a man's body.
You know, they say that they describe it that way.
They say now he's on the swim team. He
was given women athlete of the Year.
Speaker 2: So.
Speaker 3: Oh, you didn't hear, I guess. See.
Speaker 1: So pretty, pretty sick stuff and very
interesting that now interesting and disgusting
that now the transphobia is just a staple of
when Trump speaks to crowds. So we will pause
there. You can if you're if you're so inclined,
you can find all these clips on her Instagram at
David Pakman. So after the break, we'll look at
what some of the other speakers said. And we need
to be. This these events can't be ignored because
as sick as they are, the right knows exactly what
they're doing and the left is doing nothing. So
we'll be right back with more from Tampa, Florida.